[Music]
the people in New York City still of
course dealing with the damage left from
Hurricane sandy lower Manhattan took one
of the biggest hits streets still
flooded subways are still down there is
no power still below 36th Street
but not to worry here to cheer up the
people of lower Manhattan is one of our
writers Dion call di
[Music]
Thank You Conan obviously the people of
New York are dealing with a devastating
situation at the hurricane sandy and my
heart truly goes out to all of them but
hey people will lower Manhattan cheer up
and welcome to being black I'm sorry
Dion what do you mean welcome to being
black calling in the hardships of lower
Manhattan black people be dealing with
that every day
I mean like no choice but to ride the
bus can't get a cab everybody's late for
work
neighborhood property value going down
you call the cops they don't come for
hours cell phone doesn't work because
either the power's out or you got sprint
he the way it just doesn't work
and look finding five people to sleep in
one bedroom at one time we invented that
I mean okay we took that from the Puerto
Ricans but uh shout out to the amigos
anyway a flood or no flood hardships are
our comfort zone okay well okay Deion
any advice for these people well look
don't worry enjoy this moment of unity
and brotherhood because you'll be back
on your hailing cabs cell phone talking
king-size bed sleeping police lovin whoo
that was scary thank God I'm not black
lifestyle in no time very
Dion call what a wonderful person